thousands and thousands way above 10 20
30 000
i don't know i was telling them all over
europe i was young i was on experience
i got cheated and i have to learn the
trade the business you know
from ground up and those lessons i never
forget
because those lessons also hurt
frank m ray dickner thank you for
joining me all the way from switzerland
it is an honor to have you here thank
you
you're welcome michael pleasure to be
with you i came across your fascinating
exhibition at the
gtex conference in dubai i've been
following
since then wind speed and i've been
admiring your concepts your innovations
and your thought process behind the
automotive industry
and where we're headed frank it's very
rare to meet somebody who's been
running a company a privately held
company for more than 40 years
and making such a such a big impact on
the automotive world and the your
industry
can you go back and share with me first
about your life how do you get to start
wind speed while you're a student at the
technical university
but also i believe that the first thing
that you were doing with green speed is
very different from what you're actually
doing today
well hey michael you know if i answer
you this question in detail
we can talk for the next four hours so i
have to make it like the company's name
speed
yes in a search way
i was always passionate about
special mobility that started already
with my bicycle and then
it continued and uh coincidence had it
that
after my ib i was working in los angeles
and i got the smell of real life and not
studies
so at the age of 21 i got self-employed
and thereafter it's history it's
shaping the tuning industry building
concept cars since 27 years
and so you really haven't been working
for anybody since you're 21 is that
right
yes i was basically always except some
student jobs always self-employed
and i i couldn't imagine having a boss
except that my customers are my bosses
but a real boss no
no way i love that so you start off by
importing
sun roofs from the u.s what what was
that about
talk to me a little about what was
happening back then why was that
the first movement that you thought was
an interesting
place in the market well it was it's
kind of easy
uh every day going to work i drove by a
body shop in santa monica
and one of those days i saw a sunroof
which you could
install aftermarket into your car it was
brand new
yeah it was aftermarket it was brand new
for the states
and it was non-existent or not known in
europe so i bought one for my car
installed it cut a hole my parents
almost flipped you know i
cut up the gold in my student's car and
then people in the street saw it they
said well could you get me one
i said sure i can and i got one five ten
fifty
five hundred five thousand and it just
happened
so how many sunroofs did you end up
selling and
i never made the calculation of all of
them but
must be i mean the thousands and
thousands way above 10
20 30 000 i don't know i was selling
them all over europe
i was young i was unexperienced i got
cheated
and i have to learn the trade the
business you know
from ground up and those lessons i never
forget
because those lessons also hurt can you
share with me a few of those lessons for
young entrepreneurs
like myself that are watching this and
have an opportunity here to listen to
a fascinating journey you know
when you get older the ex the advantage
is that you have more experience that
you have more knowledge when you're
young
obviously you don't have that you don't
know people as well you don't have a
network
so you know i took a check as granted
money
but as it turns out the check is just
paper
if the bank doesn't operate you know
it's a bad check
and all kind of things of that and that
what people tell you
the promise is some of them
become real and some not and you have to
start to differentiate whom to trust
whom to believe
and uh but that's all course of life
uh everybody who goes into business you
know
uh gets this way but when you're
employed the
the money comes out of the company's
pocket also the losses
and when you're self-employed i started
with no money
then it comes out of my own and
that's what i have the big advantage
today i have the experience
i have the network and young people you
know they often they
first run and then they think
and now i have learned over the years to
first think and then
run and it does not depending on the
speed of the running it depends
on the depth of thinking i just love
that
frank you are today fast forward you
know 40 years you're
an innovator at heart and you're
creating these concept cars for the
future
of the automotive industry was there a
turning point where you said okay
rent speed is not just about importing
sunroofs but it is about
you know being on the forefront of the
cutting edge of the new mobility space
in the 90s after having
been in the tuning industry for uh 15
17 years i thought this becomes kind of
boring
so i started to build my own vehicles my
concept cars
and then 13 years ago i said well the
tuning industry
it's just repetitive uh it's great to
make money
but actually i never worked for money in
the first place
i always worked first for my heart
and then i was lucky enough to touch
wood
that i could make a living out of it and
i think this should be the way to go
because if you're just concentrating on
how to optimize your income
i don't think your success will be
lasting
so i sold my junior activities some 13
years ago to a competitor because
it was also kind of a spread between
zero emission with concept cars and the
tuning industry calls for loud v8
engines so but to realize that 13 years
ago in 2007
seven tesla had maybe six eight or ten
employees you know was a
very small company it was a normal
industry
the new mobility as we call it today but
i asked my boss which is my wife at home
and i said listen
do you come for the next ride for the
next challenge
and she said sure let's go and uh it was
one of the best business decisions i
have taken in life
frank that that's incredible by the way
you're talking about following your
heart and your passion
but you're starting off you get into
this space by observing that you know
los angeles has these sunroofs after
market that you can install on your own
car
and then you realize there's a market
demand are you passionate about cars
are you passionate about the automotive
industry
not really i drive a stock mercedes-benz
uh i you know for me
what i do is profession obviously i love
mobility i love my job but
if if there's a place where i'm
passionate that's about boats
that's where you know because it's not
attached to business it's not attached
to
you know the whole the whole environment
boating i just do for the
pure fun and the pure pleasure so
but it's the passion for me to create to
write
to be and to go you know the extra mile
to think out of the box
uh to to maybe not
sum some strings together other people
don't and our advantage being small
being
neutral is we don't have a backpack of
the past
i can switch my business case overnight
whereas the big oems obviously they have
to maintain their employees their
business strategies
they have an ice and now they have to
change it to
electrification so it's much more
difficult for them
plus we can look at all aspects which i
personally think is extremely important
in mobility
it's not only about a mechanical vehicle
it is a lot about emotions it's about
perception
about tradition and and and it's
if you just look at the individual parts
of it i think you're gonna get lost
and at the end of the day the consumer
has to accept
what you're offering if he doesn't
accept he doesn't buy or doesn't
use it so this is what i think we can do
well
is to go above in all times you sadly go
in the helicopter and look down
today you you use it your own
but to get the whole picture and not
just a part of it
right i believe that there's a famous
quote by ford who said
you know if you would have asked people
what they really wanted they would have
said i want a faster horse
right yes and really i think what you're
describing here is exactly that you're
building
these concept cars which are really
changing the paradigm of how we interact
emotionally but mechanically and
tangibly with these cars
and you have to interface with these
emotions and you're not asking i guess
people hey what do you want in
a new type of vehicle you're really
trying to to shake to pave the way
towards the future of automotive
mobility right
plus to make it attractive you know
people have to love it
uh people are hesitant to change
we all try to remain within our old
known world
and especially in central europe you
know tested
the very famous saying we have done it
for 20 years or 50 years why should we
change it
and because you're getting out of your
comfort zone and you have to go for new
things
and obviously new things could be
positive but they also could be negative
right so many people stay within
their sometimes painful today because
they're
afraid of the change and
i love to change the new challenges
despite i'm swiss and you know i'm very
stable in what i'm doing i'm doing green
sleep for the 30 years
but this is brain food
you know i to do just a repetitive job
everything is the same every day every
year
that would be nothing for me so the
challenge to
and the eagerness to curiosity of what
the future has in store
for me is really what drives me i i love
that can you share with me a few of
those ideas for these concept cars what
type of cars we're talking about
just to paint me and the audience a
picture i had the pleasure of seeing the
website before and
and going over some of the concept cars
and and i i was i was blown away but
share with me a little bit about the
creative side of what you guys are doing
our most famous car still today our i
can so to speak
we built 13 14 years ago actually it's
the only diving car in the world
everybody knows a diving car from james
bond back in the
70s 80s the spy who loved me
but everybody knew its trick it's
hollywood it never functioned and it
actually never did
so our claim back in 2007
to build it was not that future mobility
is happening underwater
but hey you know us man we'd love to be
james bond for a day or two or three you
know
chat around the world stay in great
places
meet lovely ladies have a little fight
and then having your martini
so we just said we make this dream come
true and we prove the car could dive
it was never intended to you know repeat
it
just to have it done and that's
that's by the way a car with jill is on
the bucket list of
elon musk and i would love if he would
build it
because then we will compete you know
who dives better and who has the better
solution
i love that okay so you have a diving
car what i saw that you have different
cars for different space needs right
different
needs of a city or of people so what are
some type what are some of those types
of cars
since seven eight years we concentrate
around
automated driving what does it imply to
design
to interiors to usage
to business cases and four years ago
we invented let's call it a new modular
vehicle
but we define modular as a vehicle where
you can swap the body
depending on the purpose or the need of
the day
or the hour and that has become
extremely
fashionable now in the automotive space
everybody is working on skateboard
source in israel
and they want to explore that avenue
and that's where we are heading to to
go in depth of much more vehicles of the
advantages
what they can bring to the market
however we all know
that autonomous driving still takes some
time
depending where you are and what
circumstances it might be you know
quite a few years to come in some places
it's my
might be a little bit earlier so we
now are working on a vehicle called the
city snap which shows
already modularity of today but still
with driver
so how do you go about this whole
process
let's say you have a new idea or a new
concept that you want to design
what is the actual process of sitting
down with the team and saying we
actually want to build
this brand new car that doesn't exist
today
i'm lucky to have a team which consists
of members which are already 25 or plus
years on board so you know we we
brainstorm and brainstorming for me we
call it
flying to the moon means not to go
by increments to towards a solution but
to fly
way above it and then come back
and then you know find the solution from
flying to the moon
and then we just you know we we we we
we kick brains and we criticize
and we try to gear everybody up
and then very soon you have to go to
reality you have to go to cad
to see that what you're doing makes
sense
and physically as you cannot cheat
physics
is also doable
the only car by the way which is missing
for us is the flying car
but when you look around the industry
you see a lot of drones
but trying to do a vehicle and that we
learned with the scuba diving cars
to serve two masters water diving and
driving is already a challenge
now you want to combine the air
and this and driving for me that's
for a real car it's almost impossible
because
you call for safety for comfort on the
road but when you go
go up in the air you are calling for
light weight
and that's just simply enemy and then it
should transform
within like a split of a second from one
into the other one
so we said we won't touch that subject
because he cannot
reasonably done to get a car as we
define the car today
and to get something flying as we
define of flying because it's
awfully with today's technology or it's
almost impossible
and i have to say that i love the
addition of the way we define
a car today and the why in the way we
define
driving and flying today because i think
that what you're implying here is that
there is and needed a need for a shift
in mindset over what it what constitutes
a if you know a four-wheeled vehicle
today called the car versus what's
considered flying or
driving in general and and i i also
agree that i think that's one of the big
transitions that we will observe
what are some of your what are some of
your thought process towards the future
where are we headed in terms of mobility
how quickly do you think we're gonna get
there and what are some things that i
can potentially be excited about for
myself
i mean we're already you know deep into
electrification this is a given for me
there's no way around and no no way back
we talk about autonomous driving i
believe in it
it's coming but it takes time yet we
have to realize
with autonomous driving we need to
redefine the vehicles
now i said vehicle not a car we have to
redefine the usage and also the business
case i
100 don't believe that an autonomous car
is what we see today that's why i use
the car
that we go to the dealer we buy it
release it and then we
turn it back in after a few years you
will have a clash
with autonomous of lifespans electronics
live a short time mechanics leave a long
term
time so you have to bring it together
and that's also the father
of our modular idea to get the
mechanical life span small
by using the vehicle all day long and
not only for your personal transport
from and to work
right and if what is your prediction
regards the timeline when will i be able
to enjoy sitting in a large space
that might look a car like a car might
not but it's going to drive me from
point a to point b
and i'm going to have a different
experience than what than what i'm
having today
john krafcik ceo of raymore
he once said a very good statement
and that he said level five will never
come
and to that respect he's
right if you see black and white that
any place in the world in all
circumstances you drive automated
i follow his statement think about the
blizzard
even men or you know sometimes even
overwhelmed with what they see or not
see or you know what they have to do
so they slim it's also in technology so
a
every place every circumstance fully
autonomous vehicle
i don't think we will see but if the
weather conditions
are let's say normal within the range of
normal
light sleep snowfall is still within the
i think that will come but gradually
step by step by step by step
and it's not by coincidence that many of
those
autonomous vehicle companies test in
phoenix or in
chandler or arizona warm weather dry
weather
little rain but if you start to hit up
north in detroit you know the sub-zero
eyes onto your own
uh snowfall blizzards then you know the
challenge is
much much different right frank thank
you for being so generous with your time
and for coming on this show
i've learned a ton i got excited i think
that i'm i'm leaving here with more
inspiration to go and research this
further
and i urge anybody to go see what you're
doing because it's really it really is
phenomenal and i think that
one of the things that inspired me most
from this whole episode was this
notion that you're driven by your
passion and by your heart you're an
innovator
you don't you're not necessarily the
most passionate person about
cars in the automotive industry but
you're passionate about creating
and innovating and i think that that
really shines through your work so thank
you for that
and before we leave i have to ask you
for three words that you would use to
describe yourself
i mentioned all the three words already
you were quoting the last one it's
passion
passion about learning by the way this
is extremely important
uh curiosity obviously is very
important and last but not least to be
creative slash to think out of the box
to go different avenues but by the way
many times if you think differently you
are
a lonely person because you're not
following the mainstream
and you also have to cope with it i love
that frank
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy
safe safe here and you have a great rest
of the day
thank you very much